war in ukraine clouded investors outlook
on friday stocks fell despite a strong
u.s jobs report the economy added 678
thousand jobs in february the most since
july
that dropped the nation's unemployment
rate to 3.8 percent down from 4 percent
in january the lowest since the pandemic
began two years ago but overshadowing
that high consumer prices michael george
is here with the latest michael good
morning michelle good morning the
economy really is a mixed bag on the one
hand we've regained more than 90 percent
of the jobs lost during the pandemic but
as we all know prices americans are
paying for the basics food gas housing
are all high and they could go even
higher
among the most obvious signs rising gas
prices the national average is near 3.84
cents a gallon up 11 cents from the day
before and 26 cents from last week it's
not only impacting you in terms of your
gas prices and filling up your car
gas is an input to everything else that
we consume right all these goods that
are moving from distribution centers to
retail stores are being shipped by
trucks that consume gas for consumers
the sting of high prices is in part
because more americans are on the road
for leisure and work as the pandemic
eases that alone squeezes supplies this
is going to be a period of higher
inflation in our economy
but the economy is doing well job growth
is a leading indicator of the economy's
strength as the president noted friday
over the course of my presidency our
economy has
now created
7.4 million jobs
more jobs created in a 13-month period
than any time ever before in our history
want a job there's plenty particularly
in elkhart indiana it's in the area with
the country's lowest unemployment rate
of under one percent nationally there
are nearly two openings for every
applicant and that demand is driving
wages up average u.s earnings are now
more than 31 dollars an hour the stock
market has taken a grim view of russia's
invasion of ukraine and that may just
add to the perception of a faltering u.s
economy and so there is this perception
and i think it really is a part of a
narrative of the economy is not doing
well because gas prices are at six
dollars or because you're facing
shortages at supermarket shelves but at
the same time we're at full employment
right we're facing shortages in
supermarket shelves not because there's
not enough stuff it's because people are
demanding a lot of goods and services
and next week the fed is expected to
raise interest rates to try and rein in
inflation but there is so much
uncertainty now with ukraine the fed
chairman warns that inflation could be
pushed even higher
not good news for those of us out there
michael thank you it's